nos dicen que carla montó su bicicleta
hacia un árbol a una velocidad constante
la siguiente tabla muestra la relación
entre su distancia al árbol y la
cantidad de veces que giro la llanta
delantera así que una vez que su llanta
giro cuatro veces estaba a 22.5 metros
del árbol luego una vez que giro ocho
veces estaba a 12.5 metros del árbol
cuando giro 12 veces estaba a sólo 2.5
metros del árbol así que estaba
acercándose más y más cada vez que la
llanta aumentaba sus rotaciones de modo
que nos hacen algunas preguntas aquí nos
preguntan a qué distancia estaba el
árbol al empezar qué distancia se
desplaza carla con cada rotación cuántas
rotaciones se necesitaron para llegar al
árbol entonces como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y traten de responder estas
preguntas por su cuenta antes de hacerlo
juntos vamos a empezar con la primera
pregunta a qué distancia estaba el árbol
al empezar la forma en que yo lo
pensaría es que después de cuatro
rotaciones estamos a 22 puntos
metros del árbol vemos que si aumentamos
otras cuatro rotaciones digamos que más
cuatro rotaciones vemos que nos hemos
acercado diez metros más al árbol o que
nuestra distancia al árbol ha disminuido
en diez metros
así que escribiré menos diez metros si
queremos averiguar a qué distancia
estaba el árbol al empezar tenemos que
volver a cero rotaciones de modo que si
volvemos atrás en cuatro restamos cuatro
de las rotaciones y si vamos a una tasa
de cambio constante bueno entonces
sumaríamos diez metros
así que sumaríamos diez metros si
sumamos cuatro rotaciones nos acercamos
diez metros si eliminamos cuatro
rotaciones para volver a las cero
rotaciones
iremos diez metros más lejos así que eso
sería a los treinta y 2.5 metros de modo
que 30 y 2.5 metros es la distancia a la
que estaba el árbol al comenzar cuando
carla tenía cero rotaciones la siguiente
pregunta es qué distancia se desplaza
carla con cada rotación
de acuerdo ya vimos que con cuatro
rotaciones ella se desplaza a 10 metros
por lo que podríamos decir 10 metros con
cuatro rotaciones entonces si dividimos
ambos entre cuatro que obtendremos bueno
eso es lo mismo que 2.5 metros en una
rotación así que esto es 2.5 metros y
por último pero no menos importante
cuantas rotaciones se necesitaron para
llegar al árbol bueno sabemos que
después de 12 rotaciones ella está a
solo 2.5 metros del árbol también
sabemos que en cada rotación ella se
acerca a 2.5 metros así que sólo
necesita una rotación más para cubrir
los próximos 2.5 metros de modo que si
avanzamos una rotación más vamos a
acercarnos 2.5 metros vamos a estar 2.5
metros más cerca del árbol y estaremos
en el árbol entonces cuántas rotaciones
se necesitaron para llegar al árbol en
total 13 rotaciones
ahora es interesante pensar en lo que
acabamos de hacer en un contexto gráfico
que podrían haber visto antes podríamos
poner las rotaciones en el eje
horizontal y la distancia al árbol en el
eje vertical la distancia al árbol
llamaré al eje vertical el eje y al eje
horizontal el eje x bueno podríamos ver
aquí que tenemos 0 4 8 12 podríamos
poner hasta 16 y luego vimos que en 0
rotaciones
estamos a 32.5 metros del árbol 32.5
todo esto va a estar en metros entonces
esta primera pregunta fue realmente otra
forma de preguntar cuál es nuestra
intersección en g y en la siguiente
pregunta qué distancia se desplaza carla
con cada rotación bueno ya vimos que
cuando aumenta sus rotaciones en 4 su
distancia al árbol disminuye en 10
metros de modo que cuando esto es más 4
disminuimos 10 metros menos 10 metros
entonces realmente en lo que estábamos
pensando aquí es en la magnitud de la
pendiente la pendiente de esta línea que
describiría su distancia al árbol según
el número de rotaciones será nuestro
cambio en nuestra distancia que es menos
10 sobre nuestro cambio en las
rotaciones que es más 4 entonces la
pendiente de esta línea es menos 2.5
metros por rotación pero cuando dicen
que distancias se desplazan carla con
cada rotación se acerca en 2.5 metros su
distancia del árbol se reduce en 2.5
metros y esta última pregunta cuántas
rotaciones se necesitaron para llegar al
árbol bueno en qué punto el valor de y
que es nuestra distancia al árbol es
igual a 0 y vimos que es a las 13
rotaciones así que esta es otra forma de
pensar cuál fue la intersección en x de
modo que la línea es una línea porque
sabemos que ella se está desplazando a
una velocidad constante se ve algo así
realmente nos estaban preguntando la
intersección en
la pendiente y la intersección en x